Hello everybody.
Give me a sec.
I'm waiting for the caffeine to kick in.
I know I told you guys and I told myself I will not take a nap before my stream.
I will not take a nap before my stream.
But my body is so weak.
And the flesh... it needed the nap.
I think the worst part was that I took a nap at 12pm.
And then I was out for 4 hours.
I was out for 4 hours.
And if it wasn't for the alarm, I would have kept on sleeping.
OH MY GOOD!
This fucking skin suit!
Also... also guys.
Okay guys.
I know... This seems very weird that I am playing this game.
But I can explain.
This is PG Family friendly...
This is PG YouTube.
Please!
Also, I need to make sure I don't swear for the first 10 minutes.
Because like, I told you guys, I got fucking hit on the Vade stream.
I got hit again.
And I have to send an appeal.
And it's okay now.
It's monetized again.
But like, I can't keep having my VODs get hit for profanity.
I can't!
When did I swear?
It's over.
I already swore.
I don't even remember, guys.
I don't even remember swearing.
My brain is not on at the moment.
Anyway, chat, look.
I can explain why I picked this game to stream this week.
I can explain, guys.
Look.
I am...
I am playing Cogwheel in the master plan of content creation.
And it is not my fault that Bunny Garden is now a Flavor of the Month game.
It is not my fault!
I am merely just following the masses!
I am but a sheep for the algorithm.
I swear!
Bunny Garden is the Bunny Garden meta right now.
I swear to God!
And YouTube, please do not demonetize me, YouTube!
I just want to go to this family-friendly restaurant.
This friendly establishment.
And see some ladies.
Some women.
Who are very family-friendly.
It is PG for pretty gals.
Ha ha ha!
I...
PG for pretty gals.
That's what it means.
Guys, how is this game the meta?
I...
Don't...
Don't ask me how this game is meta!
As the fucking countless streamers are playing this game!
Don't ask me!
Ha ha ha!
Say hi!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It may be friendly... family-friendly.
But friendly fire is always on.
It's over.
Uh, YouTube, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Enough!
Cope!
Show... Okay!
Ha ha ha!
Sir!
This is a nice establishment, guys.
Ha ha ha!
I am sorry!
Guys!
This is a nice restaurant.
It's a small business chat.
That we...
We're supporting our local small businesses, everybody.
So get your money ready because these girls are gonna scam us.
Ha ha ha!
What?
Was that me?
Am I high though?
What?
What am I doing?
Why did I make such a big mistake?
I would...
Exactly!
I don't...
I would never do something like this normally.
Exactly!
Ha ha!
My comp...
Oh my god!
This is too real!
Okay!
My company fired me!
It is what it is.
It's not the first time it's happened.
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place.
Oh god!
Why am I...
Ha ha ha!
This is too real!
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place.
Ha ha ha!
I have nothing but gratitude for the company.
My boss even cried for me when they fired me.
He said, I'm sorry I couldn't help you out.
They told me that this company wasn't the right fit for me.
And that there are other places where I could shine.
It was nice of them to say that.
Okay.
Is there really somewhere out there?
Some place that would take in a fool like me?
Maybe all I needed to do was find my host club all along.
Even if I could get another job somewhere else.
I would just mess everything up for the people there.
Maybe my life is done for.
I didn't even think it had started.
Oh my god!
This is all I needed to do.
Find a nice local small business.
Time to drink my problems away.
I'm pretty sure there's a bar somewhere in this building.
Stare.
I'm sorry?
But there seems to be something thatpes out of my head.
Okay, should I read what she's telling you guys?
Or are you going to pretend that you know Japanese?
Unless you do know Japanese.
Hahaha.
Okay, I'll read it out loud for you guys.
Just throwing out a guess here.
But does something bad happen to you?
Sorry, pretend that you can listen to Japanese.
Then I'll give you a drink and forget everything.
That's why you're trying to drink and forget everything?
Or...
Are you trying to get me to go to your hostess club?
Okay, I'm bringing the volume up.
Okay.
Let me bring the volume up, guys.
The sound guy wants to hear this anime girl talk to him.
You're wrong!
What just happened to catch my eyes before I get to work?
Don't call us out like that!
You look so tired as if your life is over.
Oh my god.
Guys!
Thank god there's no eye trackers.
Guys, I hope your eyes are up here!
Or here, because you need to read what she's saying.
I hope it's up here or here, guys.
Not anywhere else.
You look so tired as if your life is over.
You might be right, Ms. Anime Girl.
I knew it!
Yatta!
Oh sorry, this isn't something to be happy about!
Oh, am I going to get taken advantage?
My financial...
My financial worry's going to get worse.
I should have hit it right on the bull's eye.
It's so sad to think your life is over.
Yeah, I know.
Someone's like, please take advantage of me.
Fuck you.
What should I do?
If I invite him, then I'll really become a tot.
If I can't leave someone so hurt out in the cold, oh woe is me.
W Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My eyes are obviously in the middle so I can do...
What do you mean?
Oh, don't worry, I brought the volume up again.
Just for you, sound guy.
Got it.
You don't have to come in the shop.
You can just have a sneak peek.
Oh, that's how they get you.
That's how they get you.
The sneak peek.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh shit, really?
You do?
You work here?
Oh!
I didn't know they opened this kind of bar there.
It's some place where I can drink with girls?
I've never been in a shop like this before.
It's clean.
Oh my god, my life is a mess.
It's clean and the girls are cute.
I guess... I guess I'll give it a try.
Oh, you're going to get me in trouble, sir.
No, are you taking that money out?
No, sir, don't take the money out.
Oh my god, we only accept a hundred dollar bill, sir.
And clearly you don't seem like you're wise.
It's not wise.
Clearly it seems it's not wise to spend that type of money.
So I can't come in?
That's all today.
I'll just give you a glimpse.
You come inside and I'm really a...
Oh no!
No!
Why did you let me see this?
If I give you the right to come to the shop as a customer, whenever you're interested, I'll be waiting for you to come.
Mr. Two, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why waste your money on host clubs when you send it to VTubers?
They're clearly superior.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Okay, you send it to VTubers who are going to host hostess clubs.
So you can get both the two experience at once.
You can live vicariously through the VTuber playing this game.
You get both the VTuber and the hostess club.
Let's see...
You're so sincere.
Your life isn't over.
You'll be okay.
I know you will.
Huh?
Right now, even if it was small, I know you smiled.
That means you're not done yet.
What?
Thank you.
I'll be here at the shop waiting for you.
I'm looking forward to the next time we can see each other.
Oh, you mean right now, right?
Alright, I'll let you go.
What was her deal?
She was so strange.
She doesn't even know me.
But...
I guess I do feel a little better.
I'm such a simple guy.
I see girls...
My...
My self-esteem, guys, is happy.
Self-esteem!
Just a simple little guy.
Now, I don't know if I really want to get drunk and forget about everything.
I'm just gonna go home.
My self-esteem is up now.
My life isn't over, huh?
No way.
Why would I take something a girl said to me seriously when I don't even know her name?
She didn't seem to be joking around.
But...
You know...
I mean...
It's not like anyone has ever told me that my life is done.
I'm the only one who thinks that.
If I don't finish it myself...
Maybe it's still possible to start again.
Oh my god, is that gorillas?
But what if they're anime girls?
Princess too.
I'm sorry for calling you...
Oh, hello?
I'm sorry for calling you without notice.
You know how you were saying work was busy?
And you need help?
Do you still need help?
If you like...
Would you...
Take me?
Am I going back already?
Oh my god, it's like Persona.
Wait, oh my god.
A lot of days passed.
It's been a week since I...
Oh, I got a new job!
I thought I called the hostess club again.
I was like, please take me.
It's been a week since I started my new job.
What should I use my money on?
That being said...
Me being positive is all thanks to her.
That'll net...
Let me spend all the money I've earned.
Just to reward her.
Should I go to that chick's shop?
This week's salary has been paid.
Payment is made every Saturday for your new job.
Spend it carefully.
Wait, what happens if I...
Okay, this week's salary has been paid.
45,000 yen.
Oh my god, what?
Wait...
There's more to this?
I'm gonna have to gamble?
Wait, what?
Oh my god!
Oh, this is so fucked up.
Oh no.
This is how they're gonna get you.
The gambling.
We're gonna go pachinko soon.
Okay.
I think there was a shop here.
I'm a bit nervous though.
Oh my god, that's her!
The customer who looked tired!
You came!
That's right.
The customer who looked tired.
I'm here.
And I have money now!
My life is so much better.
And it is here.
But you know what?
I felt like I've had it too good for too long.
So I wanna feel like what it's like to be broken.
But also have female attention.
Hello, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What kind of job does this guy have to afford a hostess bar, gambling, and vacations?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Joshua, thank you for the super chat.
You must gamble away your entire paycheck.
Look.
I can't.
If I gamble away my entire paycheck, how would I spend my money on pretty women?
Is this your first time at a place like this?
Yes.
For the stream meta.
That's right.
I've never been here before.
I see.
Well then.
I'll give you a brief explanation about how it works.
Oh, that skirt is way too short.
Thank God my head is covering the other women.
Please.
I don't know anything.
So this will help.
The name of this shop is Bunny Garden.
A fun place to drink.
That's all.
Oh.
It seems like I should understand.
But I don't.
Shady.
Thank you for the aca-soupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy moly.
Wow.
It's red.
Just like the color of her bow tie.
Right guys?
Well, you gradually get used to it.
So it's okay.
I'll be really happy with King here a lot of, lots of times.
I agree.
To do that, I have to work hard at my current job.
Well then.
Oh no.
Why are you looking at me like that?
The moment she come, she put her hands up, my eyes went to the face.
Oh, I see.
I got you.
Well then, I want you to be able to do your best.
So I hope I can give you lots of healing.
That makes sense.
I feel I can work harder if I feel better.
It's decided.
I'm sorry.
I didn't hear your order.
Order.
Did I order something?
I'm sorry, my mind is somewhere else right now.
Here you are.
This is the menu.
Maybe I'll have a drink.
What drink did you want?
A customer must purchase a drink.
A pricier drink can increase your...
Guys, did you hear that?
She said if I buy the most expensive drink, I'll be so likeable.
Okay, maybe not that expensive.
Alright, I'll give them a little sneak peek of my money.
Alright, this sparkling wine has gorgeous aroma of grape.
It's popular worldwide.
Especially... Oh my god, the women like it!
Maybe they'll share the drink with me!
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Seeing how much they have to carry...
I think those girls need the money to deal with bad problems.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I wanna confirm my order.
Oh my god.
See, this is how you do it guys.
Guys and women.
This is how you do it.
You buy a drink that women like.
So they'll wanna drink it with you.
Not because they're trying to make me order too...
Not because...
That she wants me for my money.
It's because she's...
Really thirsty guys.
You don't understand.
She's just really thirsty.
And I ordered...
Oh shi...
Hahahaha
Anyway...
It's because she's really thirsty.
And she saw me order a drink that she likes.
Because this drink is something that women likes.
That's why.
Hahahaha Joshua, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hahahaha Women will come here.
You're a high roller, dokey.
Women are temperate.
The slot machines are eternal.
Hahahaha Thank you for the Aka soup.
But thank you, thank you.
You can treat the cast members to a drink.
Some drinks are more preferred than others.
And some are easier to get drunk on.
You don't treat...
Who the fuck is she?
Give me the other girl.
Hahahaha Hahahaha You never forget your first, guys.
Hahahaha Your first hostess.
If you don't treat them to drinks, they will prioritize...
No!
I'm the only customer you should worry about.
I'm the only customer you should talk to.
Treat your cast member to a drink.
Oh my god.
I have to buy another one?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I should buy a cheap one for myself.
Because...
Hahahaha Because I don't deserve it.
And she's the queen.
Alright, here.
Here's also the red one.
Oh, it's a plastic.
Of course.
You deserve it, girl.
You fuck...
Oh my god.
Hahahaha Guys, are you looking at her head right now?
You can talk to the cast.
Something might happen.
You can gift...
You can give a gift to each cast member once a day.
Gifts can be purchased from home.
You can treat the cast members to food.
There may be a preference for different foods.
Okay.
Um...
Guys, women like it when you listen to them.
I'm getting kinda nervous.
Pro tip.
Pro tip right here.
I mean, it's gonna be the first time I meet this next customer.
My heart feels like it's going to explode from how fast it's...
Next customer?
What do you mean, next customer?
Kana?
I literally just got here and you're gonna leave me already?
Oh, what am I saying?
The purpose of this place is to make customers feel relaxed, not stressed.
If I'm in a state like this, I'm sure the customer's gonna feel the same.
Come on now.
You got this.
This is...
Guys, guys, guys.
To avoid this, you have to spend more money.
So she'll never get to the next customer, guys.
This is it.
Um...
Kaitsu.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Aiyo, remove the tutorial explanation.
Okay, let's start off with the usual.
Where...
Right here.
This is where my cursor is right now.
To her face.
Her big personality lies in the face, guys.
Lies in the face.
The first step in order to become friends, you're the customer.
So please, go ahead with everything you've got.
The first step?
Like an introduction?
So a toast or something.
What about...
Oh no.
I need to be likeable now.
Proceed and enjoy the conversation by selecting your preferred answer.
There's some things that affect likeability.
Choose your words carefully.
It's okay, guys.
I'm a woman.
I know what we like to hear.
It would be so fucked if I get this wrong.
Guys, I'm on home turf now, guys.
I'm on home turf.
I know what we like, I think.
Okay.
The first step.
Like an introduction.
Like an introduction?
You can do it, Doki!
Yes!
I knew it!
Okay, bro, bingo!
We met for the first time after all, so it's only natural to start with introductions.
Anyway, I'd love to know more about you.
I gotta lie.
Because women don't want to know the truth.
My name is Haido Kanda.
Hmm, Haido-kun.
Haido-kun.
Yeah, Haido-kun.
Got it.
Joshua, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Trying to cuck you even before the next customer comes in speedrunning the gambling route.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You don't need to keep looking at me like, guys, I can't help that my cursor keeps falling down there.
Okay, guys?
It's just natural.
It's FPS games.
Because in FPS games, you always have to aim.
in the center, okay, guys?
So my mouse is naturally in the center.
It's not my fault that she's in the center, guys.
Okay?
It's just... it's just reflexes.
My mouse... you know, like, it has to fall in the center naturally when I play FPS games.
You don't need to keep looking at me like that.
Haha, sorry.
I was just trying to remember your name and face.
I wanted to remember your name and face, you see, so I was doing my best to store that into my head.
But it's okay.
You can remember your face and name, right?
There's no need to worry.
I match your face to your name now.
So next is my turn.
It is!
I swear, Yoshi!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Super Shuriken Doki Gamer Reflex.
It is!
I naturally have my mouse in the center!
Okay, it's my turn now.
My name is Kana.
I don't mind if you give me a nickname, but I sure hope you remember me.
Of course I'll remember you, Kana.
You never forget your first, guys.
You never forget.
Alright, I'll do my best to match your name to your face then.
Kana-chan.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Hey, stop it.
You're making me all flustered.
I...
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at.
Oh, really?
Okay.
She's good.
She knows what's gonna get me to open my wallet.
She's so fucking good, guys.
If I do that, he'll be like, Stop it, dragoons!
You're making me all flustered.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at, dragoons.
Stop!
I suppose...
I suppose there are some things you need to learn from first-hand experience.
Yeah, I guess I got a little smarter from this whole situation.
Dimitri, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lock in, Doki.
This cute fictional girl game is less intimidating if you take it way too seriously and just power through.
I am taking this so seriously.
Seriously, guys.
You don't understand.
I literally spent 20,000 yen already.
That is very serious.
Tell me more about yourself, Haito-kun.
I messed up real bad at work recently.
And because of that, the boss fired me.
So I've been assisting a friend at his work ever since.
Oh, that sounds rough.
I'm okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And Zip's wallet.
If I was in your shoes, I probably wouldn't even be able to eat.
Though I'm sure words can't express just how awful you must feel.
Oh, I feel so awful, Kana.
I might need some... some affection right now.
Alright, I've got it!
I'm gonna do my absolute best in order for you to get back on your feet.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna give me personal attention!
The time you spend here will be of a constant smile.
I can assure you that much.
Oh, don't worry, Kana.
This is my own... this is my own personal feeling and want.
She did not influence me at all, guys.
But because of what she said, I must come to the Hostess Club every day now.
Like, out of my own responsibility.
Out of my own personal want.
I will spend every day with her.
Not because of anything she said.
I hope we get along, Haito-kun.
If so, I must not be a burden to you.
Haito-kun, should I get more drinks?
I wanna keep talking to you more.
Oh, Kana, me?
Only me?
Of course!
I would love to extend, Kana.
But because the Boss...
Oh, I know you can't do anything about it, Kana.
The Boss is required.
It's regulations.
I know, and I don't wanna get you fired, Kana.
I would absolutely pay more to extend my time with you.
Thank you.
I thought you were going home already.
What drink did you want?
Oh, Kana, did you... do you like the rustic?
Oh wait, I'll order something cheap.
I'm gonna let the...
Ooh, okay, I'm gonna get... beer.
I like how beer is in such a fancy glass cup.
What was it called?
Glassware.
I was like, is this still a cup?
I swear there's a different name for this.
But it's so fancy for beer.
Alright, we'll get orange juice.
I hope there's alcohol in here.
From Cassie's Liquor & Specialty.
Orange juice.
With a low alcohol percentage.
It is popular among women.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this.
Yeah, champagne glass.
Can I have some too?
Oh, don't worry.
You deserve the very best, my queen.
You get the rustic.
How much money do I have left?
30,000.
Okay, I don't need to eat.
Guys, it's okay.
I don't need to eat for the... I just go to the convening.
Every day for food.
It's okay, guys.
I just need to... I just need to go to the convene...
I can just eat at the convening every other day until my paycheck, guys.
It's okay.
Really?
Thank you.
I'll get you a bottle.
James Japanese Salary Man bankruptcy simulator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Should we eat together?
Kana?
Should we... Should we eat together?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's grab something nice.
Oh my god.
We can share...
We can share parfait together, Kana.
Yeah!
It tastes amazing.
I love this.
Oh, you wanna... You want some too?
Stare...
You're staring again.
Stream extension?
Adrian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you think about it, it's... Okay.
This is...
Okay.
I'm gonna say something that's like a bit fucked up.
But like the stream extension thing...
Sort of reminds me of...
Subathons.
It's sort of like... Subathons.
Because you're subbing to extend the stream.
Sorry.
Maybe I have a bad habit of...
Staring at things like that and trick...
I trick her, guys.
Don't tell me.
I have...
Bed hair or something?
No.
Not like that.
It's...
Nothing like that.
I thought this...
When I first saw you, Haito-kun...
But...
You seem like a really kind...
Only me...
This is the first time you told this to anybody.
Right, Kana?
Really?
I don't know if I am.
Do you want more of my money?
It's only been a little bit...
Since we first met.
So I don't know for sure.
But I'm just talking about first impression.
Oh my god!
I knew I was naturally kind-hearted.
I knew it.
But I do have a feeling you're really kind.
My first impressions tend to be accurate, you know?
I knew it.
I bet you I'm the first person to see you said this too.
I fucking knew it.
Your eyes especially.
They seem so kind.
So gentle.
Stare.
Hey!
It's no fair for you to stare back!
I'm gonna get all flustered!
Can you keep drinking, Haito-kun?
Don't push yourself, okay?
X, thank you for the 50 GIFTED CHIPS!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
And just like that, X has extended my time with you guys.
Remember to thank...
Thank you for the gifted chips.
Would you like to...
Of course!
Because my dragoons extended my time with them.
So I will extend my time with you, Kana.
Yay!
You're gonna stay a bit longer!
What drink did you want?
Oh, um...
I don't know how much money I spent.
Don't worry.
I'll drink the...
Udon Highball.
A specially selected soju mixed with Udon Tini.
It's a very easy drink and has a rich flavor and lovely scent.
Okay.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Okay, I'm a little... sort of...
Um...
I'm a little sort of broke right now.
So I hope it's okay that I go 5,000 Yen cheaper.
Uh...
Hahahaha!
You can change, girl.
No!
I refuse!
I refuse to change, girls!
She is my new Oshii.
Because she showed me just a little bit of attention and kindness.
And now I'm hers forever.
Um...
Doki Kana Extension Fund.
Katnip, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yup, yup.
It tastes great.
Oh, yes.
Oh, look up here, guys.
Hahahaha!
Wait, I can actually move it.
Mike, thank you for the Aka soup.
Thank you, thank you.
I need female attention.
Hahahaha!
Joshua, thank you for the Magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you think they are fake or what?
How dare you!
Those are not...
That is a natural hair color.
Joshua, how dare you!
This is all natural hair color.
Because that is exactly what you're trying to ask for, right?
Let's get to know more about her personality.
Hahahaha!
Oh.
Did you hear that?
You heard that, didn't you?
Be honest with me.
You heard that, right?
We heard what?
That sounded like it came from your stomach.
Oh, so you did hear that.
I'm hungry, okay?
You can't blame me.
Oh my gosh!
Are they not feeding you here?
Oh, guys, I'm also so hungry.
Hahahaha!
What should I eat when I get home?
I wonder.
Hahahaha!
Are you planning on buying something?
Are you planning on buying something on your way home?
Are you going to cook?
Hahahaha!
What do you think?
Why don't we make this a little quiz?
How hungry.
Do I tend to cook more?
Or am I the type to resort to buying pre-made stuff?
Or do I go out to eat a lot?
Oh, God.
Okay, this is a bit difficult.
My little hint to you is that I love eating rice in particular.
I could probably just eat white rice for an entire meal.
Oh, God.
Okay, wait.
I'm a woman.
I know this.
I feel like that isn't really much of a hint.
You're right.
But come on!
Answer my question!
Okay.
I think I should say cook often.
Because, like, if you're a woman, you're not supposed to cook often.
If I say buy pre-made food a lot, she'll just be like, what, you think I can't cook for myself?
So, like, I'm going to say cook often.
Good!
I knew it!
I'm a woman!
Kinda.
Good work!
Eating a ton of rice is the way to do it.
Right?
You can eat as much as you want at home.
Oh, what?
They were all correct.
I was just never was going to...
Okay.
Don't take this away from me, Kana.
To be honest, all of those options are correct.
So, depending on my mood, I'll cook, buy food, or eat out.
Wait, what's the point of this quiz?
No, no, of course not!
It was not boring!
I mean, there's no incorrect answers.
I can't think of a kind of quiz to give you.
So right, Kana!
Thank you so much, Kana!
For giving me such a generous quiz!
When you say it like that, I guess it was pretty fun.
Joshua, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you!
Everything in this establishment is a scam.
The balance, the drinks, you just drink a flashing... flaming moe in the slots.
Can't win!
But I got...
But I got personal attention.
I'm so sorry.
That's enough of a win for me, Joshua.
She is here to make me smile.
I got you the smile, Hito-kun!
No, no.
It's not done.
It's already this late?
No, Hito!
Don't!
I spent so much money, Hito.
No!
Oh my God!
Hahahaha.
Oh my god!
How much is that in US guys?
How much is that in US?
God damn please!
Oh wait, that's just the cover track.
I sent it three times.
Oh, I bought three rustics.
It's okay, it was worth it for her happiness.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will...
$320?!
For Kana's... for Kana.
For Kana.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will see you out in a good...
Look, they're so happy!
Haito who is sent off is more motivated to work and earn a higher salary for one week.
See guys?
This is a good thing.
I am making... like now I will earn more money for my... for Haito.
Oh wait, no for me.
For Kana.
I will earn more money for Kana.
High motivation for work can lead to a raise and an increase in base salary.
So what she is doing is not wrong.
It is morally right because it's making me richer.
Thank you for today!
See you later!
Yeah, thanks for everything!
See you soon!
I'll be back tomorrow.
It was such a nice place and this customer service was great!
Maybe I'll go there for the time being.
Honestly?
I thought it was pretty good.
Alright guys.
Okay, I have 10,000 yen.
And like I feel like... I can gift a member a vacation.
Like with me, right?
Like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, let us... let us go gambling.
You can try gambling.
Of course, sometimes you win and sometimes you lose.
Keep your fingers crossed and consider taking on the challenge.
Alright, we need to make money for Kana.
Epsilon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Haito is a shi...
Don't say that about my girl!
Just because she's giving me attention and not you, does not mean she's filled with lies.
You don't understand!
You never got Haito's attention!
Oh shit, that's it?
Oh my god, I gotta...
Like they all say in gambling, when you're already winning, you gotta keep going.
That's what they all say.
Kana extension fee, but...
Justine, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, but what if I... what if I can double it?
That's what they all say.
Never quit while you're ahead.
Wait, I'm Haito.
Sorry.
Sorry, Kana like messed up my brain a little bit.
I can't tell if I'm Kana or Haito anymore.
I can't tell.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
Everyone quits right before they hit it big.
Exactly.
And that is why you're right.
Look at that.
Everyone quits before they hit it big.
Come on, come on, give me that money.
Noooo.
Okay, but like, you can't end on a loss.
You can't end on a loss, guys.
Gambling?
Gambling.
It's white, that means good.
What?
Guys, you can't end on a loss!
It's okay, I have convenience.
Oh gosh!
Yeah!
Oh my god, 30!
Okay, now I should stop though.
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear...
Okay, um...
Oh sorry, we ran out of time, Zecra.
But my boss said that like...
I'm joking.
Happy birthday dear Zecra!
Happy birthday to you!
Yay!
Alright, we gotta buy a gift for...
for...
for Kana.
You can purchase...
gifts to give to the cast on rare occasions.
The lineup may change.
Guys, what do you think Kana would like?
Oh my god, do you think...
Oh, I think she'll love a plush toy.
Oh, she seems like a girl that...
that likes plushies.
Oh my god, the lux...
Okay, not gonna lie, she'll definitely like a luxurious bag.
I shouldn't buy makeup, cause then I'll be like...
She'll be like, what, you think I need makeup?
I shouldn't buy flowers, because flowers will eventually die.
So I think...
I'm gonna spend all my money...
on a plush toy.
There we go.
I won this by gambling.
It's okay guys.
It's okay.
I can...
Okay, continue.
Okay, wait, how do I get out of the store?
It's an expensive plushie.
It's okay, I win it all back by gambling.
Come on.
Come on, big money.
Big money!
There's no way I could lose.
Okay.
I might be in debt, but I can get out of debt by gambling.
It's okay.
I can get out of...
back out of...
I can get out of debt by gambling.
If you keep winning.
Oh.
I told you.
Yes.
X, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Guys.
Guys, we gotta get out of debt.
It's the only way.
Okay.
Guys, don't worry.
I can get out of debt, guys.
The loan shark that I borrowed this money from said that like...
Said I just need to pay it back by tonight, guys.
It's okay.
I don't need my knees.
Oh!
Guys, I'll be fine.
It can't get worse.
It can't...
Guys, it can't get worse.
Don't worry.
Eventually, I'll hit it big.
You just gotta take more chances.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I can win again.
I can...
No, don't gamble, Doki.
You'll lose all your money.
What money?
I don't know if you see the red sign on the top, right?
Court Jester.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, the day's over.
But I haven't finished gambling!
The day's over.
I've gotta borrow some money!
You spend more than you'll have.
You'll have a racked up debt and might even get visited by some scary people.
Let's avoid getting into debt.
Oh, thank God.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay, guys.
My job...
My job clutched it out for me.
I need to enter...
Okay, guys.
Can you see...
I need to go see Kana.
Kana!
I shaved, brushed my teeth, and got the wrinkles out of my clothes.
Okay, I'm good.
Let's go into the shop.
Keep gambling!
Yes, I'm okay!
Wait, where's Kana?
She's away on Saturday!
Okay, note this up.
Don't go see...
Go to the bunny garden on Saturday.
Okay, guys.
I'm good.
Why not having a conversation with other cast...
It's not the same.
The cast member who likes you the most will serve you immediately after you enter.
Increase your likability and you might end up...
Like...
End up with...
Married?
Kana would...
Marry me?
Back?
Doki, you may want to call in-game 1-800-GAME.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What drink did you want?
It's not the same.
Can I have a drink with you?
You don't even bother me up!
Okay, I'll give you...
You're gonna have the same drink as me.
You have to earn this.
You weren't my first.
So you have to try even harder to earn this money that I have here.
17,000 yen.
I really love this.
I mean, it's so yummy.
Sorry guys, you gotta extend your time.
Okay.
Let's have a conversation.
I mean...
Yeah, I have the music in my notebook, too.
For now.
Wait a second.
You're pretty cute.
But why are you curled in a boxer?
What's wrong?
Well...
I was here for Kana.
You don't even know my name.
You must be nervous.
That's no good.
Getting nervous over me is just a waste of energy.
Oh, hello.
Your name is Kana.
The name is Haidokanda.
It's a pleasure to make your acquaintance.
That's hilarious.
You started introducing yourself...
No, she's making fun of me!
Well then.
I will too.
Hello, I'm Rin.
I'm sorry to trouble you.
What am I doing?
Is this how it's supposed to go?
She's laughing at me, guys!
What is Hai-chan doing?
She makes me feel emasculated.
So what do you do, Hai-chan?
But she called me Hai-chan, so it's all better now.
Right now, I'm assisting an acquaintance with their job.
But until recently, I was employed at her company.
However...
How abusive!
Keep doing that!
Get it!
Fire up!
Due to a plethora of mistakes, I was terminated.
Hang on.
Hai-chan, I can't keep up with all that formal speech.
I'd be super grateful if you just talk normally.
Hana wouldn't laugh at me.
Really?
I'll drop the pretenses then.
Thank you!
Hai-chan is a kind person.
You're such a nice guy, Hai-chan!
If they're lost for firing you, you're better off without them.
You're right, Rin!
They made a fucking mistake!
No...
Oh, okay, never mind.
She's not right.
No, they treated me pretty well.
I'm getting by okay now.
You're so great, Hai-chan.
I respect you for not saying bad things about the company you're in charge of.
Wow, you're really something, Hai-chan.
You won't badmouth them even after getting fired?
I respect that.
You're a good person, Hai-chan.
You're a kind, kind, and good person.
You're a stand-up guy.
You must get that a lot, huh?
Oh...
Let me hear some more.
I don't get that at all.
My self-esteem is so bad.
Why don't you help me?
Help me out.
There it is again.
What's the name for it?
Humanity?
Oh, what was it?
It starts with an H.
Humility!
That's it!
Oh, hey, let me tell you something.
I'm serious.
Well, I'm always serious.
But now I'm seriously serious.
Meeting new people is really important, right?
In life?
I mean, so I'm really grateful to have met you, Hai-chan.
I may be far from perfect.
But I'll still do the very best I can.
I hope you're ready.
Oh my god!
How embarrassing.
What am I saying?
I'm so silly.
Well, you get the idea.
Did you catch all that?
I won't say it again.
By the way, the other girls here are all really good.
They're really nice, too.
So I think you'll like this shop a lot.
Oh my gosh, she's so nice.
She knows that she's not for me.
She doesn't care because I already spent money on her.
Did you find that I'm not your type after talking to me a few times?
Feel free to slide up next to another girl instead.
I'm not that type of girl.
Oh, it's because she...
You know it's because she has all the customers she can handle already.
She doesn't need more customers, guys.
You know Rin has already got some high rollers.
She fucking knows.
She knows I'm broke.
So she's encouraging me to look at other girls.
Because she's like, this man bought me an 800 yen...
This man bought me an 800 yen glass of alcohol.
It's okay if you want to talk to other girls.
She's too high-calorie.
She's too rich for me.
I'm not her... I don't meet her standards.
I miss Kana.
She doesn't want to waste her time on small fry.
I'm the small fry.
If I'm not your type, it'd make me pretty happy.
I'm not your type.
It'd make me pretty happy.
Well, I'll leave it at that for now.
With that said, I'll look forward to serving you, Hai-chan!
Okay, I want to talk to a blue girl here.
Oh, dang.
Time totally flies when I'm with you, Hai-chan.
What should I do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
No.
When did it get so late?
I guess I'll head back soon.
Wait, I just leave?
I want to talk to her!
What do you mean I just leave?
Thanks for everything.
See you soon.
No!
I can't believe it.
Guys...
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I'm so... Okay, maybe she'll be back.
It's not Saturday, right?
Who's birthday?
Who's she?
Somebody's birthday?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Okay, there's nothing special.
It's Sunday.
Is she there?
Kana!
That is my time to rest and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Kana!
Kana, are you here?
Oh my god!
Wait, they're both the same size.
It looks like they fucking...
put a guacamole there.
Thanks for visiting me today.
I meant same size ears, guys.
I meant...
same size ears, guys.
Their ears are the same size.
Um...
Thanks for visiting me today.
What drink did you want?
I'll take the...
I'll take the orange.
Then...
Don't we want to drink too, Kana?
Don't worry, don't worry.
I saved up just for you, Kana.
Do you want the...
bunny punch?
Okay, I might be a little...
I'm a little broke, so...
Oh, maybe some vintage umeshu.
You like that?
Oh!
She loves that!
Guys, write it down!
This is what Kana likes!
Write it down!
The vintage kamashu.
Okay, I'll give you guys...
Okay.
Kana!
Kana, Kana, Kana!
I bought you...
a gift, Kana!
I bought you a gift!
If it's okay, would you be willing to...
accept this?
I hope...
you like it.
Oh!
She... I knew it!
I fucking...
knew it!
I knew what women want!
Can I really have it?
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
We have to take care of it.
What's wrong?
You seem puzzled.
Not now.
I'm concentrating really hard on something, so...
don't talk to me right now.
Kana, what?
Why would you say that, Kana?
Huh?
I got it!
Got it!
You're right, Kana!
I was gone for one day!
Kana, you're right, Kana!
Yep, yep.
You definitely are.
There's no mistake.
It's okay.
She's just being silly, guys.
It's a joke, guys.
So that's what you got.
You forgot my name and was desperately trying to remember it?
Guys, no, she didn't...
She didn't mean it, guys.
Guys, she didn't...
She was just joking with me.
Right, Kana?
See?
I knew it!
I knew she was joking!
That's not true.
I knew from the very beginning.
I swore I knew you were an important customer to me.
Of course I knew you wouldn't remember it, Kana!
I knew it!
I almost believed the haters out there.
But my dedication to you would never unwaver, Kana.
Even if you name slipped my mind, I'd remember it instantly.
Because you're Heito-kun.
And I know you are.
You're Haito-kun, right?
Yes, I'm Haito-kun!
I am... actually... I am Haito.
I am Haito!
See?
I told you I'll get your room.
There's no way I'd forget it.
That was a relief.
JP, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
She was playing a funny joke on me and it was so funny!
Anyways, don't worry about me.
I'll never forget your name anymore.
So don't worry, okay?
Of course!
I'd never doubted you for the second, Kana.
Thanks, but I'm sure it's really hard for you to remember every customer's name like that.
Exactly, guys!
She's a very busy girl, chat.
Like, she can't just remember all our names, you know?
Like, she's...
She's so busy!
She has... This is her job!
And it's okay if she makes a mistake or two.
Yeah, I wish you all had name tags on or something, you know?
Something cute.
Like what you see a kindergartener wearing.
I know, Kana!
You're so right!
It's our fault that you can't remember our names.
And it's... And I take full responsibility, Kana.
I'm only joking, of course.
I'm a pro in my field.
Remembering names is my specialty.
Well, you did remember my name within seconds before.
Seems like you're doing great from my eyes.
I am!
I'm so kind!
You really are kind, aren't you, Haito-kun?
I'll make sure to never forget your name.
Look at that!
And that's how you do it, fellas.
That's how you... You're in.
That's how you...
You're in.
Oh my gosh.
The way she looks at me, though.
When I'm with you, Haito-kun, time just flies by just like that.
Do you think you'd... Of course!
Of course!
Do I have the money?
Yes, I know I do.
I thought you were going home.
Of course not, Kana!
What drink do I want?
I'll take the 800 yen.
Guys...
I like how they don't tell you how much you spent.
So that's how they... This is how they get you as well.
What does she like again?
She likes...
Okay.
She likes this.
Right?
Yeah, she likes this.
What do I... I'm gonna buy it again.
Yes!
Oh, this is great!
I love this!
They knew.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
How much money did I spend?
I can't tell.
They don't even tell you how much money you spent.
So, Haito-kun, what do you like to eat?
I don't know if I have any particular favorites.
In fact, I'm really picky and I'll eat almost anything.
That's why I've been eating every day at the konbini store.
So I can save my money for you, Kana.
Eh?
You can eat anything?
You're seriously not picky at all?
You mean like stones and trees?
Amazing!
If I do a video stream, I'll get a lot of views.
Anything for you.
So you'd eat up sticks and stones if I bring them to you?
That's amazing.
You might even go viral if we film that.
Of course.
You know what?
Sticks and stones aren't even that bad.
You can make soup out of it.
I was talking about edible things.
So what do you like to eat, Kana-chan?
Oh, that's a question?
I want to do a quiz to guess what my favorite food is.
Wait, are you setting me up to make my food preferences into a little quiz?
You know, I was just genuinely curious.
But I guess we could make it into a little game if you like.
Yeah, yeah.
What's my favorite food?
Sounds great!
You know I love quizzes.
So what do you think my favorite food is?
I like...
Guys...
Is this gonna be a trick question again?
Mr. Tooth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lucky for us, Doki will never forget our names.
After all, we have the name tags!
I told you it was a brilliant idea!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sushi?
Oh, cause she likes rice!
You're right!
Guys, R girl.
This is R girl.
We work together.
How about sushi?
When I go to sushi trains...
I always end up making a tower of empty plates.
I love sushi, but I can't stop eating it once I start.
I'm so hungry now that I started thinking about food.
Kana, do you want food?
Kana?
Kaito-kun, say something that makes me feel better.
Please, don't distract me.
At this rate, my head is going to end up being filled with lots of food.
And I won't be able to concentrate on getting to know you.
Do you want food?
A million stars shining in our solar system?
Stars?
Michelin?
Oh, Michelin stars!
Oh, hahaha!
It's like, Calvin?
Michelin stars!
No, I can't take my mind off food!
How about history then?
You know, famous Japanese battles?
I'm just sure that won't lead back to food.
History...
In the past...
In the Edo period...
Ninja...
Monja...
How does she know about Michelin stars?
Oh, okay!
Oh no!
She has high taste, guys!
Hahaha!
History...
Ancient times...
The Edo period...
And ninjas!
Mmm... Traditional Japanese street food!
I guess anything I say right now is just going to lead back to food somehow.
Kaito-kun, what about alcohol?
I'm still okay.
Guys, do I have 3,000 yen?
Hahaha!
Should I get you more drinks?
I can keep going, but only continue if I want to.
Guys, do I have 3,000 yen?
This is important!
Hahaha!
No!
I'm sorry, Kanna!
I'm broke for the day!
Hahaha!
I'm sorry!
It's getting late!
I should go home soon!
But don't worry, I'll be back with more money!
Oh my god, I definitely did not have 3,000 yen!
Hahaha!
It's okay!
Another day of convenience!
Thank you for today!
See you soon!
I had a great, fun conversation!
I'm looking forward to going to work now!
Oh my god, thank you, Kanna!
You made me richer!
I got 57,000 yen!
Yay!
That means it's another day!
But what if I...
Guys, guys, okay...
Don't... guys...
All I'm saying is that...
Is that as everybody knows when it comes to gambling...
Um...
Hahaha!
You never quit when you're ahead!
There's no way I could lose this time!
There's no way!
I've hit all my bad luck!
I used up all the bad luck, so it's only up from now!
It's red because it means good, right?
Oh, it's okay!
It's only 10,000!
Guys, it's only 10,000 yen!
So that means like this next one...
This next one is gonna be like 20,000 plus!
And I'll be up... I'll be plussed!
I knew it!
There you go!
I'm fu...
There you go, guys!
See?
You never end on a loss, chat!
You never end on a loss!
Alright, let's see...
Plus 12,000 yen...
I'm gonna buy another...
I'm gonna buy another gift for...
For Kana!
To remember our names and what's based on food!
We'll see!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay...
I think...
Guys, I have enough for a necklace!
Oh my god!
Guys, guys, guys!
Guys, I have just enough for a necklace!
I think...
I think Kana would like this!
Okay...
Is today Saturday?
Okay, guys, we're gonna...
We're gonna sleep, guys!
Because Kana's not here!
Kana's not there!
So...
We're gonna go sleep!
I still have enough for a drink!
It's okay!
I'll sleep!
I'm gonna sleep!
We don't need food!
Guys, we don't need food!
We need...
All we need is Kana!
We'll eat...
We'll eat only...
Only at the bunny garden!
Now is the time to rest up and recover!
This is the only place that can heal my mind!
It's okay...
Kana!
I'm back!
Oh, you came!
Thanks!
Of course, Kana!
What drink did you want?
I'll just take the orange.
I'll just take the cheap one.
Don't worry!
I know what you like!
You like the...
Guys, how much for a drink?
How much money do I have left?
Guys, guys...
How much money...
will always come for Kana?
I have 4,000.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna go to...
We're gonna buy her fine wine.
Maybe she'll like fine wine.
I want...
She does!
Oh, this is great!
I love this!
She likes wine too and it's cheap.
It's a little cheaper.
Joshua, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki, the slots call you.
Keep going, Kana can wait.
The lights are calling!
One person is only here for this game for the gambling.
Not for the main gameplay.
Kana, Kana, I got you, I got you a diamond necklace.
A diamond necklace?!
Okay...
I did not realize I bought a diamond necklace.
Okay, if it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
I didn't... I didn't...
Can I really have it?
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
Of course you are, Kana!
We have to take care of it.
You seem happy.
Did something happen?
You came all this way to visit me, Haito-kun?
Of course I'm happy!
Of course, Kana!
I don't care about all these other ladies!
My eyes are only for you!
Thanks, but...
You seem much happier than usual.
I see.
I guess I was able to refresh myself.
Maybe it's because I really got some time to relax during my time off recently.
Lloyd Kurosu says, Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That weird feeling when your Oshii is losing tons of money to a pretty girl when she doesn't have a huge amount of money to spare right now couldn't be me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can use your days off to the fullest then.
Um...
Oh shit, um...
Uh...
Um...
Guys, okay...
I'll say...
Slept in.
I'm gonna say it, slept in.
My... my... right?
Um, no... I don't know!
No, I do know!
Cause I know what women like.
Um...
Uh...
Uh, slept in.
Slept in, I assume?
Ah, I fucking knew it!
Nooooo!
Nicholas!
You can't look at me like that!
It feels amazing to sleep without worrying about alarm.
The sleeping throughout the whole day feels like a bit of a...
waste.
You're too young, Kana.
You don't understand.
The older you get, sleeping in is a fucking luxury.
I played with my ho- Bro!
There was no dog in this quiz!
But it's not your fault, Kana.
It's not your fault, it had to be my fault.
I could have asked about the dog.
I played with my dog for the whole day last night.
Last time I had a day off.
Oh, you have a dog?
Uh huh.
Oh, she has a chihuahua.
Not that I'll judge or anything.
He's a chihuahua called Wawa.
He's super cute.
When I call you Wawa-chin, you come up to me with your tail.
When you sleep, we always sleep together in bed.
And when you call him Wawa-chin, he wags his tail and comes to you.
When he sleeps, it's always next to me too!
Bro, like, I was just set up for failure.
I love walking.
I'll go
for a walk with you in the park.
He loves walks too.
So I take him to this really big park near my place whenever I get a day off.
That's what we did last time too.
That sounds great.
I love dogs too.
Really?
Then someday, I'll give you a nice pat, Wawa-chin.
Well, I hope you give Wawa-chin a nice pat if you ever come around.
I'll be happy to be with you.
I'm sure you'll end up enjoying his company too.
Do you think he'd be fine around me though?
I don't think so.
It's a chihuahua.
Chihuahuas hate everybody but their owners.
I wonder if he'll think I'm trying to take his master away from him.
Wawa-chin, I love you.
Who knows?
That could happen.
Wawa-chin loves me so much after all.
It should have been me.
You're trying to steal me away.
I didn't mean like that, Kana.
But if that's what you want...
What's wrong?
I'm suddenly feeling hot.
I'm sweating.
Nothing at all.
I'm feeling a little sweaty right now actually.
I wonder what's wrong with me.
Do you think you can still drink?
Guys, do I have enough?
Guys, how much money do I have?
I don't.
I spent a lot.
No.
I don't have enough money.
I'm sorry.
I just have one session.
Okay, but like being in debt for a little bit will be okay.
It's okay.
I'm good for it.
I'm gonna stay a little bit longer.
It's just a little bit in the red.
I'm good for it.
They'll know.
I can pay them back.
What drink do you want?
I'll take the orange.
Of course, Kana.
And then you can have the vintage.
It's okay.
It's just a little bit in the red, guys.
It's just a little bit.
They know I'm good for the money.
And I don't need...
Guys, I have two kidneys.
That's all I'm saying.
Guys, I have two.
Let's see here.
You had soy ramen.
You had rice for lunch, didn't you?
How did you know?
Oh, no, I didn't.
I actually did, but I'm just playing with her.
Forget that.
My vision wasn't fully accurate.
Of course, you ate rice for lunch, didn't you?
I mean, I did.
But I feel like rice is cheating when it's used in some...
Hey, shut the fuck up, Heito.
We're supposed to agree with her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Debt is temporary.
Kana is for...
Exactly.
Kana will be there for me forever, even if I'm broke.
Right, Kana?
She'll be with me even if I was poor.
Right, guys?
Joshua, Doki, Gohan.
It's time to ask her for the diamond necklace back.
Embed it on black.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Most bento boxes have rice as a side for one.
So your prediction isn't all that impressive.
What are we even...
Why am I so mean now?
Well, I don't have anything I can call steel swords.
So I thought I'd try something else.
And the more impressive, the better, right?
So I thought psychic readings would be so co...
Oh, no.
Is she an astrology girl?
It's okay.
Nobody's perfect, guys.
Right.
But you don't have any psychic powers, right?
I mean, clearly you don't when you couldn't predict what I ate.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two kidneys?
You're right.
Imagine how many super chats I can send with that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, I might be a later bloomer with my powers.
Why don't you think about all this after those powers bloom then?
Guys, nobody's perfect.
But what would I do if someone asked if I have a party trick then?
It's up to us to accept those flaws.
Except for me, I'm perfect.
Are you saying there isn't something you're super good at?
Um, I mean...
There's nothing I can think of where I'm better than the average person.
I like acting and stuff, but I'm not that good.
Guys, why don't we even play twisters?
It's not because...
Guys, I'm just...
It's not because, like, this is what I'm looking for.
But, like, I heard that there's something...
There's twister and, like, you know, it's a fun game.
Is there anything you notice when looking at me, Haito-kun?
You know, potentials for a really cool skill?
Guys, I'm...
Guys, I just wanna win, okay?
And I wanna win at twisters.
That's really it.
Let's see.
Well, you're very good at making people smile.
I'd call that a skill, Kana-chan.
Every time I see you, I get all happy, you know?
Kana-chan?
I'm guessing that's not what you wanted to hear at all?
No, that's exactly what I wanted to hear.
I just...
I...
I don't know what to say back to something like that.
What do I do, you, Haito-kun?
You're always like this.
You compliment me when I least expect.
I'm gonna have a heart attack.
Haha, sorry.
I didn't say whatever is on my mind.
I'll try to stop myself from saying stuff like that from now on.
That's right.
Always compliment the ladies.
That's even worse.
I...
I'd love to hear you compliment me.
I'll make sure to live up to your standards too.
Like, I'll do my best to make you happy.
She just wants to make me happy.
It's not about the money.
I fucking knew.
I knew it, guys.
You guys were telling me to stay away from Kana.
That she is gonna take advantage.
But she literally told me it's not about the money.
She's here for me.
You said that was my special skill, right?
Mm-hmm.
Oh...
It's been a while since I've been with you, Haito-kun.
When I'm with you, Haito-kun...
Time just flies by like that.
Do you think you can...
Of course I can, Kana.
Time sure does fly by.
What drink did you want?
Okay, I'll take the cheap orange juice.
And then...
You can get...
You know what?
I'm gonna splurge a little bit.
Just for you, Kana.
Just for you.
I'm gonna get a...
I'm gonna get like...
I'm gonna get...
Just for you.
It's okay.
It's just 10,000 yen.
It's just...
She's happy.
It's all about making her happy.
Thank you.
I'll get you a bottle.
Oh my god.
I told you it's all...
I just...
The more expensive you order, the lower the fucking thing.
I just noticed that the drink is so expensive.
The cheap drinks are up...
The cheap drinks are like here or something.
But the expensive ones are like here.
And then here.
I just...
It's like...
That's how they get you.
You can also zoom in?
Okay, like...
It's not that like I don't know how to.
But like...
Can you like...
I feel like chat doesn't know.
So why don't you tell chat like what button it is to zoom in for all the other gamers.
I know what it is, guys.
But...
You...
For all the other gamers in chat, you know.
I bet they don't know too.
Haido-kun, do you live by yourself?
Yeah.
And you?
Yep.
Ever since I moved into the city.
Well, to be honest, I guess I live in the family of two.
That place is my chihuahua.
Wawachin's house.
Just as much as it is mine.
That's true.
Dogs are family.
Gotcha.
Well, at least you won't feel lonely whenever you go home.
Especially with someone that loves you that much waiting for you.
You're totally right!
Wawa-chin really does boost my morale.
He's the main reason why I could be my best ever since I moved here.
And because he makes me so happy, I need to do my part and make his life as great as it can be.
A desire to make your dog have a wonderful life, huh?
God, fuck.
Okay, why are they so quiet?
Why are they harder now?
Okay, you know, I feel like you've already done that for him.
Okay, this has to be the right answer.
You know, I feel like you've already done that for him.
I hope he sees it that way.
I'll do my best to pamper him when I get home tonight too.
I did it!
Guys, I did it!
I got the answer right!
I might take him to dog park next time.
I'm free.
He loves running around outside after all.
Whenever you talk about Wawa-chin, your face really lights up.
I can tell you cherish him deeply.
Wawa-chin is my precious family.
I'll introduce him to you too.
Wawa-chin is family to me, so of course I love him.
I'll introduce you to him if I get the chance one day.
Guys, guys, that means she's gonna invite me to her house.
How else would I... how else would I be introduced to the dog?
I'm allowed to meet with your family?
We're in, dragons.
Putting it like that makes me feel a little nervous to be honest.
It feels like I'm greeting your family before a wedding or something.
That's just a joke but like, unless...
He might bark at you saying, I won't let you take Kana-chan.
When did it get so late?
No, Haito, no!
We still haven't done Twister!
No!
Oh my god!
Okay guys, guys, don't worry.
They know I'm good for it.
Guys, do not worry.
Now I'm more motivated to work harder.
I'll be waiting for you so please come... of course Kana, thank you for today.
I feel way better today.
I'm ready to work hard now that I'm rested.
See guys?
I'm ready to work hard because I'm rested now.
Alright, Saturday.
Oh, I gotta borrow some money.
No I don't, I just got paid.
Yes, oh thank god.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Today I'm gonna go buy... I'm gonna go buy...
Okay, I'm gonna buy her some macarons.
She must like macarons, right?
I'm gonna buy her some macarons.
And then... and then...
Wait, I can gift a vacation?
You can give a vacation to a cast member who invited you.
No!
To a place to travel!
Okay, Kana doesn't work on Saturday.
So... so I just sleep.
It's gamble time.
Is it gamble time?
No, no, no.
No, Doki, do not gamble.
Just head to bed.
Do not gamble.
Just wait for Sunday so you can go talk to Kana.
Now is my time to rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
The job hub?
But like... but...
I wanna talk to Kana.
You came, I'm glad.
Of course, Kana.
Anything for you.
Members, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your friends are waiting at your apartment.
Doki, we need to talk.
This hostess bar thing.
It's killing you.
We looked around and found a rehab with nice slot machines for you.
Let's go there tomorrow, okay?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll just get going.
I'll just get the Cassie's orange and then...
Kana, I know you love the vintage Uma shoe.
I know you love that.
It tastes great.
If you job hunt, you can make more money.
Oh, it's cute.
No!
No,
I missed out.
I just noticed this shoe.
Guys, I... guys...
It's because I...
I didn't miss out.
Lucky macarons.
Alright.
You like macarons.
Will you...
Will you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
She does!
Guys, I have a feeling she just likes everything I give her.
I'll take care of it.
I've been really forgetful recently.
I saved a shopping list on my phone the other day too.
But I completely forgot that I even made it when I got to the store.
I always forget things when I'm tired too.
Santino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Use this for your next gambling session.
Lord Kurose.
This woman thinks we're wanting her when we really just want to pet the dog until it loves us more than her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I would agree with that.
But she owns a chihuahua.
And I...
Look, it's not that I don't like chihuahuas.
But all I'm saying is that I feel like out of all the dogs in the world, if there was one dog that I think is like, you know, the personification of the devil...
If the devil was real, I think it would be the chihuahua.
The other day, I was planning on only having one bowl of rice since I've been dining.
But before I realized it, I've had three.
I feel like that has nothing to do with forgetfulness.
You just gave in to your cravings.
Like, she's almost perfect.
Except for the fact that she thinks she's psychic and also that she could be an astrology girl.
And also, like, she owns a chihuahua.
She's like, perfect.
That's not true.
I just forget about the whole rule I set myself when dieting.
That's right.
I'm going to give you a quick quiz to help you forget.
Oh, why don't I give you a quiz?
If you give me a quiz, I'll improve your memory.
So that you won't forget as much.
You know, using your brain leads to an increase in memorization.
That's why I'm giving you a quiz.
But what was I doing on the day off?
What was I doing during my day off?
Oh, right.
We were talking about that, weren't we?
That's right.
You were saying...
What was Kana doing on her day off?
Combine words while remembering previous conversation.
Women don't like...
Exactly, guys!
Women don't like it!
She went for a walk at the park with her dog.
There you go.
She went for a walk at the park.
Was it park?
Guys, of course.
Guys, I always remember, chat.
At the park with...
Was it the park, guys?
I was too...
Guys, I know.
But I'm quizzing you guys.
Do you guys remember?
I knew the answer all along, chat.
Guys, I knew the answer all along.
I just wanted to know if you guys were listening.
Of course, I remember.
I'm a woman.
I remember everything.
I like you.
Bingo!
You really were listening to what I told you.
I like how you're so attentive.
I know.
Of course, Kana.
Of course, I remember everything you say.
I need to be careful about being forgetful too.
Or else I'll never be able to go through a dieting.
I keep saying that has nothing to do with memorization.
I think it's your willpower that you need to work on.
I don't know!
This is not how you get the ladies!
You never criticize them, especially about dieting!
Kana is just like, let me ignore that because I want you to spend more money.
Kaito-kun, should I get you more drinks?
I can keep going but only continue if you want to.
Yes.
I have the money this time.
Thank you.
I thought you were going to...
Of course, I will never go home.
I'll max it out for you.
What drink?
I'll just...
Let me keep...
You know what?
I feel a little adventurous.
I feel...
I feel so adventurous right now.
I'll spend 100 yen more.
And then for you, my queen.
I'm going to...
You know what?
I'm going to give you the fine wine.
Yep, yep.
It tastes great.
Any...
Yep, yep.
It tastes great.
Wait.
It just...
It just tastes great?
Is just...
It's just great?
Wait...
No, I pressed q instead of E!
I keep forget...
I keep...
I don't know how to read.
I thought zoom.
I didn't see it zoom out.
I...
Q was zoom out, E was zoom in, but I didn't read it fully.
I just saw zoom.
I had become a kid and I was enjoying my summer vacation.
You know, catching bugs and swimming in the river.
Kind of like when I went to my grandma's place to spend the summer.
Wait, who did the throw up emote?
Oh la...
You don't understand!
This is why you don't have Kana.
Wait, what about this?
That is a nightmare.
I mean, that sounds pretty fun to me.
Right?
I thought so too in the beginning.
But then the moment said, I wish my summer vacation would go on forever.
And that forever didn't include you.
Boom!
Oh wait, a giant version of my boss crawled out of the soil and said, I'll give you a vacation for the rest of your life!
You're fired!
I feel like someone pregnant emoji.
Right, anyone would wake up screaming after that.
I thought I had overcome this by now.
But I guess me getting fired really got me emotionally.
You're not to blame though.
I mean, sure, you were genuinely shocked.
It takes time for emotional wounds to heal.
You're so right, Kana.
Free thank yous, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bunny girls, I enjoyed your company, sir.
Credit card declines.
Bunny girls, low tier god lighting appears around them.
You should...
I know that, but I just want to forget it.
How about this?
I'll make you forget those bad memories!
Freeze!
Are you saying you're going to cheer me up somehow?
You really are kind to the core, Hana.
A special drink?
It'll only cost you like the rest of your money.
I think there's a special drink we hid away in the shop storage.
I'm sure if you take a sip, your memory will fade away in an instant.
I prefer not to forget...
With something like that.
Of course, I just need more time with you so you'll get me the special drink, right?
Right, Hakana?
Is that it?
I'll take the orange juice.
Of course, of course.
And you can get the...
the vintage umashi because I know that's what you love.
Yup, yup, it tastes great!
No, I keep... guys, I need to buy new drinks!
She's already too used to the umashi!
We're looking respectfully.
Conversation.
What if like I buy food this time?
Well, buying food like increases...
Okay.
Why... do you want to share a pizza with me?
With me, Kanna?
We can share a pizza together.
Oh, this is great!
I love this!
There's so much going on today that I want...
Oh my god, you're right!
I should've gotten sushi!
It's our favorite!
You're so right!
Oh my god, this is why this is a group effort.
If all of us work together, if all the dragoons work together, we surely might score one Kanna.
You took your day off to sing and here I am complaining!
Don't worry about it.
You should relax when you get home.
It's not good to pile up your fatigue and leave it be.
Yeah, good plan.
Thanks, Haito-kun.
It's like we're all at the same bar.
Exactly!
You're like my wingman!
You're all behind me, wingmanning me.
Do you have some sort of method to get rid of fatigue?
Something easy would be great, if possible.
Not the naps.
Naps never work.
Okay, never... not the naps.
We learned that napping does not help at all.
How about eating something sweet?
How about getting a massage?
A massage... okay.
A massage.
I'm gonna say a massage.
How about getting a massage?
Not by me, of course.
But like, if you insist.
Oh, a massage?
That would be great!
Maybe I should buy a massage device.
I hope there's something that's easy to use at home.
She liked that answer, guys.
We did it.
We're so in.
Oh, and you can't forget taking a nice warm bath, too.
Just sitting there in the warm water as your pain slowly fades away.
Right.
Oh, you know, we could, you know...
We can go to the hot springs.
Wow!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm talking about the hot springs!
They just imagined me in a bathtub?
That's some forbidden territory.
You can't...
Wow!
Bro, what the fuck?
Am I getting called out for my imagination?
That didn't totally happen?
Like, you don't know that.
What do you mean, me?
She doesn't know what I was thinking about!
You were the one that brought it up.
Let's change the topic, then.
Where do you wash first when you're in the bath?
My hair.
What?
What hair?
Do you not wash your hair first?
That's where the water touches first!
How is that bad?
Because I'm...
I'm the one that suddenly...
I'm the one that shoves my clothes into the bathtub.
Wait, forget I even asked that.
The you and my mind has started to stri...
Wha...!
Wow!
Next scene.
Bro, she, she...
She's going further than I want to...
I was just thinking about the hair on my head!
What?
Oh my god!
We're living rent-free!
We're so in!
Nexi, we know what you're thinking about.
What was I thinking about?!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I can't have that happen in my head, Haito-kun!
Don't blame me!
You're the one who's imagining the whole scenario!
Does this mean we get to play Twister now?
Is it already this late?
I'll head back.
No!
Haito!
We were so in!
You don't leave when you're like literally there!
You're so fucking stupid, Haito!
Oh my god!
You don't just leave when you're literally there!
I'm waiting for you!
I'll be waiting for you, so please come again!
Yes!
Thank you for today!
Yay!
We had a good, fun conversation!
Alright, we're trying to get a better job, right?
Alright, I made 57.
Alright, is it job hunting time?
Can I actually get a better job, chat?
Oh, Haito!
The fumble is so fucking crazy!
I didn't know!
Do I actually get a better job, chat?
Yes?
Okay.
By applying on the dispatch recruitment day, you can earn money.
One dispatch consumes 2k.
Be careful not to overwork.
Alright, do you want to spend two days on dispatch?
Yes.
Let's do it.
I'm working.
71,000 yen!
Oh my god!
This is so much... Thank you for your hard work!
No!
I missed a week!
I missed a...
No!
Kana, please don't forget me!
Kana!
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna buy her some perfumes.
And I'm gonna buy her... I'm gonna buy her... um... pajamas.
And then... and then I'm gonna buy her roses.
Okay, I have gifts for all three days.
Okay, we made it.
Okay, I missed... Okay, it's okay.
Saturday...
She's not there on Saturday.
So we're gonna go gambling.
No, do you think she forgot about... me?
Guys?
Wait, do you think... No, it's still not open!
Okay, okay, okay.
We're gonna... we're gonna gamble.
Guys, guys.
No, we don't need a save, guys.
We're not save scumming!
Chat?
Guys, this is it.
This is it.
We must... we... we're so lucky right now.
We have so much money right now.
Chat?
This is it.
No, we're not gonna save.
Guys, we don't need a save cause we're gonna earn... go up.
Yes!
Okay, that's good.
I'll take that 2,000 yen.
We need to cash out.
I... I'm... I'm scared.
I'm too scared to keep going.
Bro, she's... she takes a break on Saturday.
What the fuck's the point?
Okay, we're gonna... we're gonna sleep in.
And see her on Sunday.
Alright, that was a bit scary.
Yeah, we're gonna sleep in.
She's gonna be there on Sunday.
I'll always show up on Sunday.
No, we don't need a save, guys!
We don't need a save!
I shaved, brushed my teeth, and got the wrinkles out of my clothes.
Okay, I'm good.
Let's go into the shop.
Chat?
Kana, I'm back!
Did you... do you remember me, Kana?
Of course!
Of course, Kana!
Don't worry, I'm gonna...
Kana, Kana, today is big money day.
Today...
It's...
Big... Okay, maybe not that big.
Maybe... maybe not that big money.
I just realized it's a hundred and...
Well, we'll go with the lamp pair.
It's... it's second big money day.
It's almost big money day.
Today is I.O.
money day.
I'm not ready yet.
I'm...
Of course!
I'm ready, guys.
I'm ready.
Oh, it's all the way down there.
Kana, Kana, I...
Kana, I got you... I got you perfume, Kana.
Hanover...
Will you be willing to accept this, Kana?
Ah!
She likes it!
I'll take care of it.
Of course!
Of course, Kana!
Is your blood type O?
But... Oh yeah, there's like... in Asia culture, it's like...
A blood type is like a personality trait.
Actually, it is.
How did you know?
Well, you have a carefree vibe about you.
I know, especially with money, right?
So you based it off of a blood type personality test?
I don't know how accurate something like that is.
Well, whether you believe it or not isn't important.
What's important is that I can believe it.
I can lead the conversation.
Well, let's see.
Would your blood type be...
Guys, okay, I actually don't like... care about the blood type personality...
Holy shit!
So...
I see that like astrology.
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All this and you're somehow less of a simp than you are while playing Hello Kitty Island Adventure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, what is a good blood type?
What is a good one?
Is it A, B, A, B?
I don't know what the blood types are!
A, B is supposed to be the ganky one.
We use them... A, B is normal.
So, B is more common.
A, B is the universal recipient.
A, B is good because it's a universal recipient, guys.
A, B is superior.
A is for kind people.
A, B is two-faced.
Always... guys, I feel like a lot of you guys don't even know as well.
Okay.
A or B?
I'm gonna go with A.
I'm gonna go with A because A is always a good blood type, right?
A perhaps?
Yes!
Are you suggesting I'm metathorical person, serious and sincere too?
I knew it!
My Asian genes spoke to me.
Because A is always better than B.
Serious and sincere too?
You know me too well.
We're so in.
The correct answer was O type.
The same...
Okay!
I didn't even get that as a choice!
I don't care too much about the details.
And I'm pretty easygoing, wouldn't you say?
Well, when you put it that way, I suppose I see that inside of you.
But if I said you were a metathorical or emotional person, I wouldn't be able to tell you.
For example, you feel that way too, right?
I guess you're right.
Sorry.
I thought it could be...
Oh my gosh!
Why am I so bad at this?
Why is Haito always...
Haito, I worked so hard trying to get you Kana.
But you always f**k it up, Haito.
Why do you do this to me?
I spent so much of our money for her.
No, I should be the one apologizing.
You went through all that trouble thinking up of someone to talk about.
Right, what blood type are your parents?
My dad is A.
And my mom is B.
But I don't know why you're bringing this up where their personalities are nothing like their readings.
I don't know!
I even bought her the second most expensive wine!
Sorry.
I can't even control this!
Bro, I can't control incompetence!
I'll do my best not to ruin the vibes like that again.
Gambit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blood type tomato juice.
Self sabotage.
I just want to tease you a little in return.
That's all.
Whoopsie.
Of course.
Of course, Kana.
Let's get more twinks.
Alright.
I'll drink the Cassie's orange.
And then you go.
Okay, look, I already gave you like the second most expensive so we're gonna...
We're just gonna go back to the usual.
Well, why don't we try...
Why don't we try bunny trap?
We can afford a little splurge.
Yep, yep.
It tastes great!
Alright.
We'll look at the most respectable part of the body.
The hair.
Uh, I can't gift any more presents today?
Oh, don't worry.
We can buy sushi.
We can buy sushi because I know how much you love sushi and I have the extra money right now.
Yep, yep.
It tastes great.
Kana, didn't you say that... Okay, Kana.
You're perfect.
Ice cream.
Cake.
Nah.
Mochi is an option too.
Hmm.
Damn you, Doki.
Hahaha.
Are you thinking about what to have for dessert when you get home?
She's always hungry.
How did you know?
That looked like I was that hungry for some sugary treats?
I mean, you were the one mothering about it though.
I guess you didn't realize that you said that.
I want to eat all three to be honest.
I'm hungry.
Ice cream.
Cake.
Mochi.
They're all amazing.
I know I can destroy all three in a heartbeat.
But...
But if I do something so extreme at night, I'll regret it.
I did something so extreme at night, I know I'll wake up in the middle of the night with nothing but regret for my actions.
Well, eating too much is never good for your body either.
You should probably just choose the one.
Guys, what do you think she likes the most, guys?
Did she ever tell me what she likes?
She never told me what dessert she likes the most!
How am I... Okay, what's the best dessert?
How about cake?
Hahaha.
Mochi, cake, ice cream.
Okay.
Cake.
It has to be cake, right?
Cake... cake is... is universally loved.
There's so many different flavors with cake.
Chocolate cake.
I actually bought some chocolate cake last night, so I need to eat it while it's fresh.
Yeah, that's def...
I did it!
I knew it!
I made the right choice without any help whatsoever.
Maybe I should just eat it all.
I can't decide.
I love them all equally.
Nice guess, Doki.
Hahaha.
It's not a guess.
I know the way to Kana's heart and not you.
And they're made to be enjoyed after all.
I think it's my civil duty to enjoy them all to their fullest.
Yup, that's my civil duty!
Oh my gosh, that was a very long sentence she said for, yup, that's my civil duty.
I'm worried you're gonna have an upset stomach by the end of this.
I'm gonna have to drink some more.
You can keep drinking, Haito-kun.
Don't... of course I can.
Anything for you.
I'll stay here forever.
Of course.
I'll take my... I'm gonna be a little adventurous, guys, and I think I'm gonna get some beer.
I'll be... I'll spend... I'll spend like a hundred yen more.
Hahaha.
It's just a hundred yen more.
Woop.
Looking at her hair.
Hahaha.
Alright, conversation time.
Alright, so what do you have, uh, when you, so what do you do when you have spare time at home?
I play with Chihuahua's mom.
Even though we've been playing since the day before, I've been playing since night.
I always play with Wawa-Chan, my chihuahua.
I'll start to play with him and by the time I realize, it ends up being the dead of night.
If anything, maybe Wawa-Chan is looking after you.
What do you do at home, Haito-kun?
Well, video games for one.
I'll play on console.
I'll play on a... Oh my gosh, I have hit rock bottom.
I'll play on a console I have at home.
Then play a little bit on my phone.
Oh no, I'm also a gacha gamer.
Before I sleep.
Where's my PC?
I have a PC!
What happened to Steam?
I'm literally playing this on Steam!
Games... Kana?
You not like video games, Kana?
After I spent like... I'm pretty sure I spent like...
Like more than 5k on here.
Like American 5000 dollars.
And now you're gonna tell me games, huh?
Oh, do you dislike video games, Kana?
Please answer wisely, Kana.
Oh!
Oh, thank god!
I was gonna say that was my deal breaker.
It would've been over.
Console is cool too.
Yes, but not just console!
I need to expand your horizons!
You need to expand them!
There's also PC gaming!
Hahaha!
Nope, I love them actually.
But that's exactly why I made myself stop playing.
And I end up being really loud, you see.
Oh, is it because of... Don't worry, my apartment has soundproof so if you, you know...
Wait, no, that's not what I mean!
For gaming!
So neighbors won't complain for gaming!
What the hell are you doing?
You haven't lost yet!
No!
I won't... I'll say things like, I'll get you or damn you!
I won't... Oh my god, she's toxic!
She's perfect!
You know, the usual.
I'm trying to hold back, but I'm always out of it.
Am I trying to hold back?
I'll be back to shutting by the time I realize it.
That's why I love you, but I'm sealing you.
So...
That's why I forced myself to shut you out.
I'm trying to stop playing.
I don't want to cause any disturbances to my neighbors, you know?
That's what I heard.
I heard in Japan it's really hard to get like a place that was soundproofing for streamers.
Because like, you know, especially like streamers are like really loud and stuff.
Like you can get like called on by the police and stuff very easily.
That's a bit of a shame.
I never knew you were so passionate.
Oh my god, thank god she's perfect.
I thought she was gonna judge me for my gaming.
I was ready to go to another girl.
I was so fucking ready to be like, bye.
Don't you play puzzle games instead of something that's so action focused?
You know, something that uses your...
Haito, what the fuck?
Why would you suggest puzzle games?
Oh my god.
Haito does not represent me.
I would have walked away.
It's all the same.
I end up being overly passionate even if I'm solving a puzzle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kana says gamer words.
I'll be loud from being so hyper after beating a tough puzzle.
And similarly, I'll be loud if I can beat a harder puzzle.
In a way, I'm jealous of how passionate you are towards video games.
Oh my god.
I'll buy you one right now.
Who cares if I need the loan money, Kana?
If I ever become rich, I'll buy a soundproof room.
And then I'll play video games to my heart's content.
So I'll be patient for now.
Do you want something to take with you?
You know, maybe something that symbolizes our friendship?
I have something perfect.
Yes?
Yes, Kana?
Oh!
Okay.
It's time.
Oh my god.
Cast members may invite you to play mini games.
You can pay a fee?
Okay.
Alright.
And enjoy.
She's like, can I invite you after hours?
By the way, it'll be 100,000 yen.
Like...
Oh!
A pony!
Yes!
Of course!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna get a Polaroid photo!
This is not Twister.
You select the pose and take a photo.
You can check the photos you took from your home.
As your likability increases, the number of poses increases as well.
Okay.
What the fuck does chicken...
Guys, I think I know what chicken meat means.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I'm trying to figure out the best one.
Okay.
No.
This one, her hands.
I don't like where her hands...
I don't like...
Like... where...
I don't...
I don't like where her hands are.
Alright.
Maybe...
Bunny ears?
Bunny ears, right?
I don't know, guys.
Or...
But...
I'm trying to decide!
It's so difficult!
What the fuck is chicken...
You know what the fuck chicken meat is.
You know...
Don't act ignorant to me about chicken meat.
Okay.
Maybe we'll do...
We'll do...
You know what?
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait.
Guys, we're here for the eyes, right?
We're here for the eyes.
Oh, what about like...
Okay.
Ooh.
Look at that beautiful hand.
Okay.
What about the hands, though?
Guys!
What about the hands?
Oh, what?
No!
I didn't mean to!
There's a time limit!
This is nice.
I didn't know that!
I'm glad you came again, Kana.
Oh, my.
Tell us, Doki, what does this mean?
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God!
I thought I could...
I...
I hope you have beautiful hands, Kana.
Guys!
This is all I wanted!
Phew.
It was fun, wasn't it?
I was sweating a little.
Oh, could they give us super chat?
Thank you.
Thank you, Zahando.
Oh, it's getting late.
I should go home soon.
That was so much money.
Okay, that was...
She's happy, though!
I'll be waiting for you, so please come back again!
Yes, thank you for today.
Thank you, Kana.
Yay!
I get to drink delicious alcohol and have fun conversations.
Now I'm motivated for work.
Hon George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
100% safe for work.
Nice, Doki.
How was I supposed to know?
Guys, we have to earn money.
Guys, we need money, guys.
We have to work for Kana.
Kana, don't forget about me!
Kana, I'm earning more money for you!
Okay, thank you for your hard work.
Alright.
No, goodbye.
Goodbye!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Kana, Kana, Kana!
What should I drink today?
Beer, wine, champagne?
Let's just get in there first.
Kana, Kana, Kana!
She's here!
She was waiting!
For me!
I'll get the Cassis Orange, please.
Of course.
Can I...
You know what?
I think this will get me the Twister.
I think this will get me Twister, guys.
I'm gonna do it.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I would get Twister.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm sorry.
Guys...
It's okay!
A little bit of debt is okay!
Guys!
It'll just be a little bit of debt!
Our dinner is actually over.
It doesn't work like that.
What do you mean?!
It's not the time.
Yes, but it's okay!
I can...
I can go into a little bit of debt!
it's fine...
I swear.
It's too dangerous.
You guys are cowards!
Olive, if you don't spend it all for your one true hostess, then what's the point?
Do it for her!
Really?
I'll get you a bottle!
Do it for her!
Wow!
It's a different color!
Kana, Kana, Kana!
I also got you pajamas!
It's okay.
Will you be willing to accept this?
Accept this?
I hope you like it.
Can I really have it?
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
Of course, Kana!
Anything for you!
There's something I want to talk to you about.
What is it?
What is it, Kana?
It's okay.
I have two livers.
I have two livers... No, wait.
I have one.
I have two kidneys, two eyes, two ears, two hands, two feet.
I don't need two.
One can do the job.
The function.
Actually, forget I mentioned it.
No, no, tell me!
I spent a hundred!
I spent a hundred and eighty thousand yen on you!
For my one true doki, I guess.
Thank you for the super chat, Santina.
Thank you.
Two lives!
I can live with half a liver!
This time is to make you feel good, Haito-kun.
So I can't go and bring my own issues.
No, no!
I'm a good listener, Kana!
Not at all.
I'll do anything I can to listen to your problems.
Thank you, Haito-kun.
Thanks, Haito-kun.
Then, I'll be kind to you.
I might take up your offer of kindness then.
I have ten fingers?
I don't need ten fingers!
I'll contact you when I get a liver.
Yeah, your liver regrows, technically!
I'll be happy to help you.
My dad from back in the countryside called me.
He told me to come back.
I still have things I want to do here, so I told him I can't go home.
But there's still so much I want to do here, so I told him that I won't return home.
Don't listen to your father, listen to me!
I see.
I'm sure he's just worried about his own daughter who lives so far away from him.
I can donate so much!
Anything for Kana.
I know, but that's exactly why I feel a little guilty when I mention not wanting to come back.
I'll be your...
I'll be your new dad.
Hold on.
I never talked to you about my family back home, right?
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm learning so many new strats from the stream.
All these unnecessary organs I never see anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I remember you bringing them up briefly.
Remember when we talked about blood types?
Let's see.
Oh.
Dad and mom are A and B, right?
Dad and mom.
Kaz, I know the answer.
But do you know the answer?
Kaz, I know what the answers are.
But do you know what it is?
What was it?
I'm gonna test you guys.
Yeah, yeah, you do.
Oh yeah?
Prove it!
Prove that you know the answer, chat.
Unless you're lying to me.
I always knew.
I already knew.
Oh wow.
I can't believe you even remembered that.
I'm kind of happy that you knew it.
Of course, Kana.
As someone that spent at least $10,000 on you, I'll always remember.
I'm making my dad sad, aren't I?
I don't want him to feel that way at all.
I won't deny that he doesn't feel sad.
But I'm sure he'll come back to understand your desire to stay there.
I mean, you're telling him how you really feel after all.
He'll be proud of you and accept your viewpoint for sure.
I'm sure.
Thanks, Haito-kun.
Of course!
Of course, Kana!
I can't go home yet because I need to still achieve my goals here.
But do my...
What goals?
I'm actually curious what their goals are.
I'll do my best not to make my dad feel sad too.
I'll call him and talk to him.
I'll talk to him.
Maybe I should call him more often.
Oh, and I have to mention you to him too, of course.
Yes.
That's all dads want to hear.
The guy that's giving so much money to his daughter for her to give attention to him.
That's what all dads want to hear in the countryside.
I'll tell him how much you uplift me whenever we talk... with money.
But if I tell him that, he might take it in the wrong way.
You wouldn't like that, would you?
I'll keep it a secret from you, Haito-kun.
I'll keep it a secret from you.
Maybe I'll stay quiet about you for the time being then.
No, I won't.
I don't want to be your secret.
I want to be public, Kana.
Kana, I already told my mom about you, Kana.
Should I get you more drinks?
Of course, yes.
Yes, a little bit of debt won't hurt anybody.
I'm going to be so happy later.
Okay, I can't afford much right now.
Okay, apparently somebody said get the special highball.
Because that's her favorite, so I believe you.
It tastes amazing!
I love this!
I fucking knew it!
That someone was me.
I told myself that.
Alright.
Her beautiful...
Her beautiful bunny tail.
Okay, I already gave her a present, right?
So...
Um...
Should we have... Let's have food.
Okay, food.
We'll have...
You know what?
We'll have... You know, we'll try candies.
She likes sweet stuff.
This is great.
I love this!
Skeleon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Who paid money for attention?
Weird.
Doki, decipher me, please.
Should I make a ginger chewy cookie?
Or hazelnut brown butter cake?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
You know what?
Get the brown butter cake.
Kana likes cake.
So now we all like cake.
I already bought sushi.
She didn't give me like a nice answer.
I feel like my hair is getting kinda long.
Maybe I should book an appointment at the hairdresser soon.
How much would it cost?
I got you.
Like short or long or something.
I don't think I have any sort of preference like that.
I like...
I like Kana shaped hair.
Then, how about hair color?
How about hair color then?
Do you like brighter tones or something darker?
Lighter colors are nice.
But so are darker ones.
Look, my entire preferences is just you now, okay?
I...
I'm a little annoyed at how much you don't seem to care all that much.
I don't care what other people think.
It's like how like girls are like, do you notice anything different?
And the guys are just like, uh...
Your hair...
I think you can at least seem a little more interested, you know?
It feels like you don't care about my hair at all.
Sorry, I wasn't trying to say that at all.
I'm saying that you could pull off any hairstyle or color.
I really don't mean that.
I really do mean that.
Sorry, I really do mean that.
Of course!
Kana, you're doubting me already?
I bought you the fucking 150k yen champagne!
And I only had 146!
I do.
Besides not having a preference isn't necessarily a bad thing, is it?
That means you can make anything work, Kana!
I can promise you that no matter what hairstyle you decide to go with, I'll visit you the same amount as always.
Look, I haven't even talked to another woman!
I only talk to you, Kana!
I'm sure I'll become more attracted to you going forward, but I'll never start disliking you because you changed your appearance.
If
you say something like that, I can't say anything back.
That's so unfair, Haito-kun.
I can't say anything back when you say something so kind like, Oh my god, Haito, you did it!
You finally clutched it!
For once in your life!
Of course!
Let's talk more!
Alright.
I'll get my... You know what?
I'll change it up.
I'll get the oolong highball.
And then, I know you love the special highball.
It tastes amazing!
I love this!
Yay!
Her beautiful hair that we all love.
And her beautiful hands that I have a photo of.
Okay, I'm not reading that out.
What are you doing?
I'm just practicing my pronunciation.
You know how this job is all about talking with others, right?
So I do all sorts of vocal exercises.
So I don't mess up my words.
Oh, your enunciation, huh?
I suppose that would make sense to practice so you don't fumble your sentences.
I say as I never practice and now you can tell why I...
You can tell why I pronounce things the way I do.
She sells seashells by the seashore.
Okay, that is definitely not it.
That's definitely not the translation to what she said.
Tone twisters, impressive.
You didn't even stumble, Kana-chan.
I used to be in the drama club back in the day, actually.
We used to do this sort of practice all the time.
You were in the drama club?
Now I'm curious.
Did you mainly practice acting?
Okay, I don't think I should say these.
Okay, did you mainly practice acting?
You're not an actor?
Then why the fuck were you doing fucking word exercise?
Why the fuck...
Okay.
Of course I would assume you're an actor for doing word exercise.
I was on the sound team.
And...
I was literally... I was like the sound... I was a behind the scenes sound team.
We did not practice fucking sound exercise.
Actors are the pinnacle of what most people in drama want to become.
Aren't they?
But I wasn't like that.
I was part of the lighting crew.
I was like lighting and sound.
I was part of the lighting and sound crew.
Given the actors, their spotlight, and thinking about light positions and whatnot...
Mostly on the lights, though.
I worked mostly on the lights.
But if we needed... if our sound guy wasn't there...
Like, I would like attempt to do the sound.
Because I had like seniority.
But I was like... I was... what was it called?
Like the... the crew... the crew in charge.
The behind the scenes crew.
I actually got like... back then...
Okay, sorry Akana.
This is my turn to share my story.
But like... in one... one of the years...
Back then, I think in like high school...
There was a convention slash conference for like...
Theater people.
One time I was selected for like the drama side.
But like the second time I was selected to do the behind the scenes.
And like only several students...
I think like only three people are selected per school...
To go represent the school.
For this like... drama conference or whatever.
And basically like...
Each school selects three students.
One will be the band.
One will be like the... from the band class.
One will be in the acting.
And the other will be like the technician.
So I got selected for...
One time I got selected for acting.
And then the other time I got selected for technician.
So like I've done like...
Technician and acting for the conference.
And then it's basically all the students...
From each school come together...
And produce like some show.
Like it's there to like improve your knowledge.
Um...
It's to improve your knowledge and your skill set.
And then they all come together.
Like each school comes together...
To make this giant show based off of like...
Um...
All these like really talented individuals in each like sector.
And uh...
And that's why this is...
Um...
It's so f******t that she was like...
I was part of the lighting...
Lighting crew.
And she's trying to like bait me with the pronunciation.
Like how is that supposed to know she wasn't lightning?
How?
How is it supposed to know she wasn't lighting?
And she talked about pronunciation...
And tongue twisters.
I see.
I just assumed that most people in the drama club...
Will want to act more than anything.
F**king poser...
Did I tell you the honest truth?
I wanted to act too.
Look guys, this is why I'm not an actor.
I don't do tongue twisters.
Of course I fumble with my words.
She was right!
I fumble with my words!
That's why I joined to begin with.
Sara, thank you.
Seriously, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Girl could come back.
Thank you for your super chat by the way!
Girl could come back looking like a tomato.
Little does she know we're into that.
Thank you for existing, Doki.
I didn't have the courage to act in front of an audience.
So I panicked and went for the lighting crew...
position instead.
Don't get me wrong.
I enjoyed doing the lighting.
I really did give it my all.
While learning the importance of behind the scenes work.
Also for the conference, we had to travel.
So it's not like in our area.
The school would pay for the travel cost to whatever school was hosting it at that time.
But because I was working behind the scenes, I could see the actor performing in the spotlight from so close.
So we would travel really far at one point.
My dreams kept getting bigger and bigger while me really striving towards them.
And that brings me to today, I guess.
I'd love to see you in action one of these days.
Working on the lights, Kana-chan.
She's told me she wants to be a fucking actor!
Well, I guess I could do my best to try once again.
I hope one day I can bring you the good news that I'm back at it.
Yes!
I'm going to be a good actor!
Oh, come on!
Twister, twister, twister, twister!
Yeah!
I'm sure you'll have fun if you went through with it.
Come on, let's do it!
Oh my god, yes!
Please don't be the hand game!
It's a 50-50!
Yes!
You can spin the roulette every time you pay a fee!
The castle moves their limbs according to the instructions given on the roulette wheel.
Have fun and see how long you can last.
Alright, let's start.
Okay, you first, Kana-chan.
Right hand on yellow.
Oh my god!
Okay, let's have an over...
Oh...
Okay, yes, spin the roulette.
I can keep going.
Left foot on red.
Wow!
What the fuck!
I'm sure dad is very happy about your job!
Wow!
Okay, spin again.
She won the...
I won the 50-50, guys!
Alright, left hand on yellow!
There we go!
Can I like...
Okay, yeah.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, okay.
There we go.
Spin the roulette.
Yes, I guess we keep spinning!
Right foot on red.
Where's the...
Oh god.
I...
Guys, I'm gonna have to look up.
I feel...
I feel like it'll...
No!
So, lower angle, you'll be like this, right?
Wow!
There we go!
Okay, right foot on... okay.
Guys.
Guys, I feel like... guys.
Okay, I feel like I need to step in real fast.
There we go.
Okay.
But I got this.
What do you mean?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You don't want me here?
Phew.
It was fun.
Wasn't it?
I was sweating a little.
I've been so locked in in my life.
When it gets so late, I guess I'll head back soon.
Oh my god.
Oh, hey, nice.
Nice.
Alright.
I want to be with you a little longer.
Oh my god.
You're so in.
I don't want to just say bye to you now, but I don't want you to feel pressured by now either.
When the cast members are in a good mood, you might be invited to afters.
Going out with the cast members outside the shop.
It seems that you'll treat...
Of course.
I'll do it.
It'll cost you to go after.
You're so in.
Yes.
Let's go somewhere right now.
Okay, guys.
We're going to do it.
Let's go somewhere.
Really?
I guess you wanted to be with me somewhere.
Guys, we got to.
She wants to do after hours.
No, you're blocking Kana Episod.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is my gambling.
I'll leave the location up to you.
I know it'll be fun no matter where we go.
If I'm with you.
Okay, she's going to get ready.
She's going to change.
Oh my God.
I'm so in.
Why are you crying?
Why?
Is it because I'm broke?
I can't.
I just use my handkerchief.
Oh my God.
Where are we going to go with negative cash?
I'm so in.
Don't look at my face too much.
I didn't think I was going to cry this much.
My face looks awful.
Oh, did we just finish watching a movie?
That was amazing.
I think this has definitely landed my top three movies now.
Oh, guys, I don't even get to see that movie.
That's how broke I was.
They cut off the movie content.
Your face?
I think so too.
I like this.
Just previous work.
But this might be my face.
It's my favorite.
You sure know your movies, Kana-chan.
I'm trying to be an actress, remember?
I watch a bunch of movies.
But movies are definitely more fun to watch with friends rather than by yourself.
And talk about your thoughts afterwards.
About things you like or what scenes stood out.
That sort of thing is super fun.
Fun!
Usually I watch things by myself, but you might be right about this one, Kana-chan.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna kajumbo it.
I need to write a review of this movie the moment I get home.
You write reviews?
Yep, I write them down to journal my thoughts.
Things like which scenes I remember or which actors stood out.
Are you gonna write about the twister?
But today's journaling might end up being a bit more than just a movie review.
Oh no, she's gonna write about the twister.
What do you mean?
It's another 15k for the movie.
Because I watched it with you.
I feel like I'm gonna end up writing more about my time with you.
Just please don't show it to your dad, Kana.
Just don't let your family see it.
Just don't let them see your journal.
That's all I ask.
I'd love to read the end result.
Nope, not even a sentence because it's a secret.
Oh god.
Oh my god, it's night time.
She's gonna give me a gift?
Oh, birthday ticket!
Is this an invitation to your birthday?
Yes.
It's my birthday.
Her birthday is coming up.
I hope I can spend it with you.
Wait, what do we get to do on her birthday?
Why is Doki in the...
You know why.
You know why it's in the raid.
Thanks, Kana-chan.
The movie you saw today was amazing.
Wait, I have to save up for it?
What do you mean?
Did you have fun?
Because I basically bought her presents.
You had to... you get to buy her presents?
Did you... Of course I did!
Of course I did!
Because I was with you!
Right.
There is another movie around the corner that looks really good.
I hope we can watch that one together.
Then, let's go to Wawa's house Chigawa is waiting for.
You'll have to be careful and go home.
I need to go home to see Wawa-chan.
You stay safe going home too, okay?
Right, tell Wawa-chan I said hi.
I'll see you later.
Oh my god, I have an after-fees?
Okay...
That's really... Is that $150?
How fucking expensive was the... Why is the club charging me the money?
Why is the hostess club charging me the...
Isn't that $150 US?
Or like a hundred... Why is the movie so...
It's a hundred... Why is it a hundred dollars for the movie?
Movie tickets are like... I don't know... 20, 30?
At least I feel so good at work.
Did you buy snacks?
I got the... I spent way too much money.
I don't have enough money.
I need to borrow.
Oh my god, when is her birthday?
It literally doesn't... Okay.
It's on August 13th.
Wait, what's the shop?
Oh my god!
When are you ever gonna wear this dress?
A hundred and fifty thousand...
Oh my god... Oh my god...
Guys, I think this... Guys, I got to play Twister.
I think this is a good time to call it.
I got what I wanted.
Guys, I... Guys, I got... I got Twister.
I think that's okay.
That's... We peaked, guys.
Guys, we peaked from there.
We... All we wanted to do was play Twister.
I think that was the perfect time to call it.
I think...
I think it was...
Daisy!
Daisy, give me the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm fucking... I'm in debt right now.
I can't buy anything.
I'm literally in debt.
Chat!
Guys, it's okay.
I had a good day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm 200,000 yen in debt from host clubs and the collectors are busting down my door to break my kneecaps.
Let's go!
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys... Guys, we...
We lost so much money, but it was all for Kana.
It was all for Kana, the best girl.
We did it, chat.
We fucking did it.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We made it.
We peaked.
I feel so motivated, chat.
I feel so fucking motivated now.
That was...
That was an adventure.
That truly was an adventure.
I think it was good that we didn't keep going.
Because I'm worried that I think the mafia was actually going to go for me if I kept going.
So, like, we gotta know when to quit, you know?
We gotta...
Guys, I think I like my body organs.
Guys, I think, like, you know...
I thought about it.
And, like, I feel like maybe I do need to get...
I think I do need to get both my kidneys, you know, chat?
Maybe...
Maybe I do need both my kidneys and both my lungs.
I don't know.
Just a maybe.
Rampa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow, Doki.
You're just gonna twist her and leave?
Yes.
Absolutely.
After Kana fucking charged me a hundred dollars for the fucking movie tickets.
I don't know, guys.
Like, I thought she was perfect.
But then she buys movie snacks.
So, like...
So...
So, I don't know.
I feel like that's a little bit of a red flag.
That's a little bit of...
She buys a hundred dollars worth of movie snacks.
So, like, I feel like it's a little bit of a red flag, guys.
Echo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine being dead from a gacha game.
Conan B.
Doki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She bought sort of like sixty dollars worth of movie food.
And that's like one popcorn and a coke.
And like, at that point, I feel like, you know, Kana might be a little too rich for me.
For my taste.
Granny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Broken Bun, thank you for the super chat.
Got a gamble to make even for Kana's birthday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Glad to know Doki has the same spending habits we do.
It's reassuring knowing we're all broke together.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
It wouldn't hurt to gamble, right?
We're...
Alright, guys.
Guys, okay.
We're just gonna...
Guys, all I'm saying is that we might as well...
I'm saying...
We might as well...
What's the worst that could happen?
You know?
Oh, shit.
Okay, guys.
We can continue.
What's the worst that could happen, guys?
Like, you...
We can't get worse, guys.
We can't...
We can get worse, possibly.
Right?
Oh, guys.
What's the worst that could happen?
Surely, this is it.
You have to lose some to gain money.
Chat.
Like, it's not gonna come in for free.
You have to take risks to get your money.
Oh, shit.
Oh, see!
9,000.
We can keep going.
I told you.
And the next one will be, like, plus 20,000 after that, guys.
Actually, that would be, like, plus 20k.
Because what's the worst that could happen?
Like, I could lose more.
Now, see?
It's just 1,000 yen.
That's just $10.
Being, like, 500...
Like...
No, it's okay.
I'm good for my money.
You guys know that.
Okay, but...
Okay, maybe I should stop.
Maybe I... I mean, 100k and...
That is up exactly, Kaz!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's okay!
The government will bail me out!
The creosus at this level of depth.
That isn't a red flag.
It's a ba... See, I told you!
25,000 yen!
Guys, I'm almost out of debt!
Guys... guys, I'm almost out of debt.
And don't worry, the government can bail me out.
I can... I feel it.
I feel the government bail out, guys.
See, look at... Don't worry, if I go any lower, the government will be like, Oh my gosh, here's some free money.
We feel so... so bad for you!
Super Shock, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki, the type of person to twist and tell.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We can keep going.
Guys, we can keep going.
The house is me!
I'm the house!
The house always wins!
That's what they mean!
See?
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm gonna win like 25k after this.
Guys, I'm gonna win 25k.
This is it.
One super chat equals one gambling.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See?
Look at that!
And then I'm hitting my win streak.
Oh no.
Do I have money?
Oh, I gotta... I gotta raise!
Guys!
I gotta raise!
There's a swimsuit event?
Oh my god.
No, no.
You gotta cash out.
You're gonna be in for too long.
You'll keep playing this forever.
Anyway guys, we're gonna call it here everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated.
We're gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had...
had a great time everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time with this stream.
If you guys want to watch more of Bunny Garden, don't worry.
Everybody is streaming it.
So...
So if you want to learn more about what's going on...
Or you can play it yourself!
You can play it yourself.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for more, I'll see you guys in the next video.
Bye!
And head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!